est ce que vous avez fait qu'est ce
qu'on va faire payer les attend la
viande est notre corps à corps avec des
tomates grillées
oui et comme dessert des bananes sans
but
oui voilà dont va être entré le charbon
de bois
on va la famille mais non cas et on va
l'allumer d'accord oui alors à mettre
sur la table
moi je vais aller ça m'a plombé bon
laisser flamber vous en occupez pas
pendant ce temps là je vais jouer c'est
ce à quoi sert la cud alors je vais vous
apprendre une chose info les tomates on
a un truc j'ai créé d'extraordinaires
canton s'est grillé des tomates sur un
arbitre on enlève le centre de la tomate
voit comme ça avec un trou
dans ce groupe on complique
ils vont se faire voilà on met un tout
petit peu de sel et tout à l'heure
justement nos bêtes sur la grille quand
mettra de l'huile et lui il va rentrer
absolument tout la tomate le ciel va
rentrer et ça va sentir le talent j'ai
très très bien et on continue comme ça
pour tout l'été
oui pour la vie on regarde si tu veux
qu'une viande électrique ne devienne
jamais noir si on a revécu dupont
microcell et tu frottes et à viande avec
comme ça
[Musique]
voilà et elle va devenir aa qui à 12h06
qui a mis des sucres sur la viande
c'est vrai qu'ils me donnent de l'huile
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
alors regardons mais une goutte d'huile
dans la tomate comme sahara et on pose
la tomate mais enfin tout cela qui la
pose à côté de l'autre sommacal pas trop
son passé les bornes surtout pas que ça
des banques parce que ça alors là ça va
brûler vim
[Musique]
on met la viande aussi
non non
ça marche ça va non seulement non
seulement tout arrive mais ça va flamber
doit pas masquer au soleil
[Applaudissements]
bon alors les tomates sont cuites avant
christine donne moi le place au complet
nous allons est posée
vous
sur le flanc si vous n'aimez pas les
tomates vous n'aurez rien dans voilà
c'est comment vous ferez vous voulez
qu'on fasse on peut jouer au robin des
bois vous irez vous cherchez des verts
[Musique]
allez maintenant aller manger je veux
pas savoir mais bon alors c'était bon
oui emmené en mérinos est très curieuse
dans les bahamas alors qu'ils voient les
bananes on va les fossés sur le grill
comme ça simplement
alors là pour wii bien quand la peau va
être tout noir
on va les retourner de l'autre côté pour
que la peau soir ce noir les deux côtés
et quand la peau sera noire des deux
côtés on va les reposer sur le plat et
simplement enlevé le 2 cl c'est à dire
tirer une peau de banane et quand on
aura tiré une photo nandre la sucre et
la madame sera entièrement fondu et on
va manger ça n'est touché plus regarder
ça va devenir tout noir c'est pas grave
il faut que cela soit noir quand c'est
noir c'est bon c'est d'accord oui
touchez pas
tu voi à l'intérieur elles sont
complètement son but en trois matches
andy égaler mais il ya de la fumée
un jour on passe rien faire du tout à
bercy ne sera pas semblé regard jaloux
bon nous on les laisse cuire encore de
l'autre côté allez là même le plat sécu
des deux côtés et c'est maintenant qu'on
va être renversé
[Musique]
maintenant les bananes sont cuites on va
se brûler un peu en enlevant la peau du
dossier mais ça vaut le coup un bon si
on fait ça pour toutes les bananes
allez bon appétit
[Musique]